make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so continuing on with the immortal
Hulk man here is the thing I've been
reading The Incredible Hulk for years
right like even before Greg packs run
like I've ever eaten incredible whole
three years and for the most part the
story's always just kind of seemed to be
rehashed that's why Greg packs run was
so cool like Greg packs run basically
did things that we hadn't seen before
like you had yet bill man no yet Peter
day but it was like okay the
psychological torment of Bruce banners
father on Bruce himself and the reason
why we have the whole kernel like kind
of stuff and then for something like 20
years
he was basically just sort of like
filling stories right like The
Incredible Hulk smashing things now you
know and so on and then Greg patch run
brings in like black Planet Hulk and
World War Hulk and you know what we're
hope you're smashing all that kind of
stuff you get like these really really
cool stories and then like al Ewing
comes along and turns the entire thing
on its head because the way this ends is
nuts it's one of the coolest things ever
I don't even think most of you guys know
who it is that shows up at the end and
it kind of makes sense because he's only
ever really appeared like once but what
this does is it initially kind of picks
up with it with really with like Rick
Jones right because that's one of the
things that really kind of came in with
the stories that we saw was that Rick
Jones's body was taken and Betty Ross
was shot in the head right it was really
a way for like a Ewing to kind of thin
the herd so to speak of like the
Incredible Hulk mythos or at least that
seemed to be the case but what it does
is it kind of switches over to a -
Jackie McGee I remember Jackie McGee is
the reporter that we've seen over the
course of a Ewing's run on on the
immortal Hulk so it works in terms of
hurdles kind of being here and and
really ever since the events of like the
Incredible Hulk in Hell where she was
part of she's like okay I kind of like
sit back and just not be a part of
anything right now because what I've
seen was crazy and so I need to kind of
regain my bearings get back to a state
of normalcy and try to figure it out and
her bosses like felt like no you're not
either here's like we need you to go
please you go figure out what's going on
with the fact that a giant hole was
smashed in the house of Betty Ross and
like something's going on here right so
there's basically like get back into the
Incredible Hulk investigation and that
kind of stuff which is kind of wild
that's over here you end up picking up
with with Bruce Banner and with doc
Samson now doc Samson is a character
that we haven't really talked about much
before and in all honesty there's not
really been a reason - I mean Leonard
Samson's okay but basically he's he's
infected with gamma radiation but he
never really turns into a tried and true
Hulk right like the green scan and all
that kind of stuff
instead his hair just turns green
whenever he taps into his super-strength
now he's not infinitely strong right
there is a finite level to his strength
but in reality he's always kind of been
more of an outlier in the Hulk family
than anything else but I've always had
this
I consider him to be that way it's one
of these things where he's a guy that
that Bruce usually always goes to
whenever he needs help right I mean it
was doc Samson who was working with
Bruce Banner when we got professor holt
when we ended up getting great hulk
merging with with savage hulk and then
creating like a whole new personality
doc stands and usually always been kind
of like the psychologist behind what's
going on with bruce but he also works
with him outside of that stuff too so
it's it's kind of cool for what it is
but again he's just sort of here and
bruce essentially says hey look there's
things going on here but my memory is a
little blocked i can't really fit in all
the pieces we need the incredible hulk
to do the rest now this is one of the
things that that al ewing is really kind
of touched on when it's come to the
incredible hulk and really kind of
establish that wasn't really there
before whatever came to the Incredible
Hulk he would just manifest there have
been times over the years when Bruce
Banner and the Incredible Hulk have kind
of worked together and Bruce can bring
the Hulk out and say hey man we need
your buddy and the whole could be like
okay and then he'll pop up and do his
thing but more often than not they've
been conflicting personalities and when
that happens basically Bruce doesn't
really remember anything the Incredible
Hulk does again there have been
instances where he does but it's not
normally part of the mythos but one of
the things that al Ewing is really kind
of established here is an almost
werewolf kind of situation where the
Incredible Hulk comes out at night and
Bruce Banner comes out during the day
it's kind of a cool thing now valuing
does not dismiss the notion of the
Incredible Hulk popping up when he needs
to but one of the things that he focuses
on is that if Bruce banners in the
presence of like UV rays of sunlight
then the incredible hoax is not gonna be
able to pop up it's kind of cool the
fact remains the incredible folks able
to kind of fill in the missing pieces
and so when him and Doc Sampson break
into the shadow based facility that
Bruce Banner was previously held at this
in turn leads to like all these
gamma-irradiated animals right now this
is kind of cool because what this does
if you guys who've been reading Marvel
for a long time
this really hints hard with different
notes of like weapons Plus right like
that's what it feels like weapons plus
was like was it was like weapon one was
Captain America right like if you go
back and you read Grant Morrison's x-men
I think it was Captain America was
weapon one nobody knew how to duplicate
the super soldiers here so what you got
under weapons Plus is you got weapon one
with Captain America then you got two
through nine which is just random
experiments trying to create super
soldiers then you got weapon 10 which
was Wolverine and then you got
characters after that you got Deadpool
you got phantom X you got the Stepford
cuckoos you got like all these different
versions but this is what this feels
like and so what they've been doing is
like a radiating animals with gamma
radiation to see what happens you've got
like gamma-irradiated bats you've got a
gamma-irradiated dog is what it looks
like you've got a gamma-irradiated
gorilla which actually looks awesome
what they're also doing is they're
basically rapping someone or something
in a cocoon with the intention of like
creating another gamma-irradiated beast
and it's kind of an interesting thing
because when that happens what we end up
finding out at least once all these
animals are destroyed is that basically
this was a trap that had been set these
were basically a distraction and when
that whole thing pops off it'll
basically lead to like the defeat of the
Hulk or at least the attempt to defeat
what they didn't account for was the
sudden emission of solar rays like
ultraviolet rays and when that happens
the Incredible Hulk is forced back into
Bruce banners form and then they're met
by the arrival of Bushwhacker now
bushwhackers been here since really that
like the beginning for the most part of
aliens run but Bushwhacker is an
old-school character he was created back
in 1987 it was a daredevil comic a
number which one but it was it was and
Sinti and rick Leonardi i think is who
it was uh but basically he was just like
this guy who was a not really a contract
killer well kind of I mean he really
kind of was right like the idea was he
built on mutant hysteria
originally when he was created on
meeting hysteria and sort of taking out
mutants Wolverine figured it out and
then his wife thought he was crazy and
so the result was that Wolverine started
tracking down Bushwhacker and then his
wife basically went to that Murdock and
was like we got to get this guy
committed and ultimately led select the
two of them coming into conflict in an
effort to catch Bushwhacker
they didn't and ultimately like like
Karl ended up going to work for kingpin
I think it was and then after that he
just kind of free-floating Marvel Comics
for years but it's kind of a cool thing
because with with Bushwhacker getting
the upper hand on Bruce what Bushwhacker
didn't account for is the arrival of Joe
fix it right like the return of Joe fix
at home now Joe fiction Hagen in fact is
kind of cool because al Ewing sort of
covers this in the store but we can
explain it here Joe fix it Hulk is
really more of like mobster whole and in
truth he's the original form so in in
terms of like real world publications
the accreditor was originally great most
all of you guys probably know that the
six-issue miniseries Marvel had to
change them to green because of printing
issues but what Marvel never explained
in the comics is why the Incredible Hulk
originally showed up gray and then
turned green it wasn't until later on
down the line that Joe fix-it was
introduced the what Marvel said is that
in terms of the Incredible Hulk
continuity appearances which is to say
inside the comics in the Marvel Universe
which Hulk came first it was Joe fix-it
that when Bruce Banner was first blasted
by the gamma radiation he turned into
Joe fix-it then Joe fix-it went dormant
and then the savage Hulk came out and
he'd been that way ever since but one of
the things that goes on here is he can't
actually transform into the grey Hulk
persona because of the solar rays so his
basically Bruce Banner with the strength
of Joe fix her at least part of the
strength to Joe fix it but then he
doesn't have
ability to like heal from anything and
so when you have someone like
Bushwhacker who's got cybernetic
enhancements what it does is it gives
Bushwhacker the upper hand over Bruce
Banner himself and so when that happens
and Joe fix-it has to basically rely on
like ingenuity and intelligence in order
to be able to pull it off and that's
kind of the cool thing because with
these enhancements again Bushwhacker
does stuff like make his arm make his
hand into like a gun different things
like that but when he goes through he
basically manages so like hacked the
lighting system and when that happens he
starts sorting through all these
different wavelengths ultimately
reaching gamma radiation and when that
happens like you just start like because
of so gamma is so much gamma radiation
at one time it kind of overwhelms his
body he turns in like this giant
crazy-looking Hulk form and then like
smashes Bushwhacker and actually ends up
killing him but then we end up finding
out that what-what shadow base has been
working on here is creating a new
version of abomination and this new
abomination is that they've been working
on is actually Rick John so it's kind of
a way to kind of bring the Rick Jones
concept back and then just sort of go
forward from there but what this does is
it switches over to Jackie McGee and
then it jumps into the character of
Betty Ross and we find out she's not
actually dead she's at what really seems
to have happened is she seems to have
evolved this is one of the things that
no one's ever really seemed to hit on
when it comes to the Incredible Hulk
mythos and is actually a new concept as
far as I'm aware when it comes to the
Incredible Hulk one of the things to
bear in mind is that it really is a
mutation of genes but the gene mutation
is unstable right that's the reason why
Bruce Banner can go from like the
Incredible Hulk and back again his genes
literally change from one form to
another but it would make sense that
there would be like a next stage of
evolution that like any one of the
Hulk's could reach and turn into
something else with the mutant
population it was like that for years
right Lee the mutants were just like a
singular a singular power right like a
meat and pops up their powers manifest
and then they have those powers
forevermore
it wasn't until Grant Morrison's run on
new x-men there's suddenly we got
secondary mutations doesn't happen all
the time but it can that's how I'm a
fraud Scott her diamond form and that
seems to be what's going on here with
Betty Ross so like she's basically
mutated and transformed into like a new
version of like a new kind of Hulk that
we haven't seen before now the reason
why this matters and the reason why this
is important is not because Betty Ross
is a new version of Hulk because it sets
a precedent because what it means is
that from this point going forward
how will you in can at any point change
the Incredible Hulk into something else
the status quo is maintained and it
makes sense and so from here like you
literally have Bruce Banner who goes to
essentially like Vegas basically like
goes to this this really shoddy looking
hotel and then starts talking to the
Incred
hook through a mirror right and what he
says is there's these versions of
ourselves did we haven't really
accounted for or at least that are out
there somewhere right so like savage
hope childhood is a really good one
devil Hulk this is the first time we've
seen it referencing quite some time Joe
fix it Hulk we have Bruce himself then
you got professor green scar Hulk who we
have not seen since Jonathan Hickman's
run on Avengers and New Avengers when
the Incredible Hulk was running around
so there are these versions of Bruce
these versions of Hulk that Bruce cannot
account for and doesn't know where they
are but then we've also got this new
immortal Hulk as it was kind of cool
because Bruce is basically sitting down
and reconciling all these versions of
himself really kind of a Ewing saying
here are the verses of Hulk that that I
care about and here are the ones that
you'll most likely see over over the
course of the immortal Hulk story but
then of course they're met by the
arrival of the new abomination in the
form of Rick Jones now abomination when
it was Emil Blonsky was just like this
violent guy who destroyed things that
was really all it was with this version
he's actually kind of got a mutation in
the sense that what it does is it
basically consumes other people right I
mean it really seems to consume their
heads more than anything else but what
it also has the ability to do is spew
this kind of stomach acid that really
seems to like negate the healing factor
of the Incredible Hulk right and we know
that's because when that happens the
Incredible Hulk hand is basically like
like dissolved and destroyed it doesn't
come back and so what this does is
create a kind of final weakness for the
Incredible Hulk where does it say this
version of abomination is the deadliest
one we've seen before
now there isn't wise because again
unlike Emil Blonsky this one can emit an
asset that will take away from the
healing factor of the Hulk right so it's
like the Muramasa blade of Wolverine or
like carbonadium when it comes to
anybody with a healing factor it's a
cool little way for al you and to kind
of reach out into the mythos of what
Marvel's done so far and then grab these
small little tidbits and roll them in
but these forces of shadow base which
basically kind of destroy these loose
ends these folks who witnessed what
happened they're running out of the
hotel when they take them out now
they're met by the arrival of Betty Ross
is like this giant bird Hulk looking
thing which is actually incredibly
violent
she's like ripping people's heads off
and like tearing off their legs and like
gutting them and it's just like the most
violent thing ever and it's amazing dude
I I do tell you I love this I love this
is actually pretty awesome but
nonetheless this version of Betty she is
still coherent to a degree but she's not
like her former self right she's
actually seems to be a little more
simple in terms of her function when she
was red she-hulk
she was a lot more in control of herself
and able to function like a normal
coherent human being and this one she's
almost kind of reverted to like a very
base form and while shadow base is
watching all this unfold and the Obama
and is let you know seems to be like
tearing up the Incredible Hulk and
really like has done a number on him
taken his eyes and so on and so forth
and left him for dead Betty Ross where
it would seem that she was gonna go save
her gonna go fight a fight abomination
instead she turns on the Incredible Hulk
rips his heart out and then eats it and
so it's kind of like okay so like
basically The Incredible Hulk dead now
and everyone's turned on him and so what
this does is it switches through spanner
being sent back to hell right like being
sent back to the realm of the one below
all were again he basically meets with
his meets with the one below all in the
form of his father but then we get this
sort of information drop that we didn't
have before that al Ewing is really
again kind of interjecting and changing
things up so when it came to gamma
radiation in Marvel Comics for years it
was just one of the various forms of
light wavelengths right like that was
really it it was just an energy that was
out there you could blast somebody with
gamma radiation or whatever but it was
basically just a form of ultra like a
form of light ray was established here
by Al viewing is what he says is that in
this instance that's not all of it like
it is oh it is a light ring that's true
but it's also like the other half of it
is also like energy that basically is
emitted from like the realm of the one
below off the Bruce Banner exists partly
because the one below all allowed him to
write at the one below was always
looking for a way to kind of escape his
realm and enter into like the main
Marvel Universe essentially like being
Satan more or less right like Satan's
desire to escape hell and then show up
in earth and wreak havoc among you know
all kinds of crazy stuff that kind of
seems to be the case here and is cool
because what it says is that like Bruce
Banner like you are essentially part and
parcel to the realm of health this is
where you belong by virtue of everything
that's happened the energy you need to
become the Incredible Hulk is here what
triggers it is the gamma radiation light
that exists out there in the main Marvel
Universe The Incredible Hulk couldn't
exist if the one below all didn't exist
it's kind of a crazy thing because the
response of Bruce is like there's no way
that's true that can't be the case but
the response to the one below all is no
but it is that like it's an absolute
truth but here's the issue and this is
why I like what it isn't a looming does
we don't know if he's telling the truth
we don't know if he's being honest like
you could kind of assume he is but
there's no reason to believe he is right
because of the one below all is kind of
like this prime version of evil right
like this absolute evil in which all
other forms of evil stem from all of
their demons and things like that like a
fist oh and so on and so forth if all
that's the case then like there's no
reason to believe that it would be
telling the truth
if being deceptive and in being
duplicitous but basically lead to his
goals being achieved so again it's a
cool little moment here because in the
middle of all this what suddenly happens
is Bruce Banner wakes back up
right like he pops back up the
Incredible Hulk manifests again and
starts tearing into abomination it
actually seems to rip him apart pretty
easy right the fights over
like that I mean it's over in the blink
of an eye and so from there like of
course Jackie McGee shows up and she's
like what the heck's going on like I
thought you were dead and it's kind of a
cool explanation here what Al Ewing says
is that the Incredible Hulk having his
heart ripped out jump-started his
healing factor because remember the
Incredible Hulk exists as
self-preservation it that's that's the
the most important charter of the
Incredible Hulk
that's why it is in the comics whenever
Bruce Banner was was like fatally
wounded and The Incredible Hulk popping
up would save him that's exactly what
would happen the Hulk exists to save
himself and the only way the whole can
really exist is if Bruce banners
physical form exists right there have
been a few instances where that's not
been the case where they've been
separated from each other that's not the
status quo that's not the norm they
always end up merging back into a
singular being again the only other
exception to that is during the doctrine
run I think it was when Doctor Doom
created a new host body and basically
put banner in this new body and then the
Incredible Hulk went forward and banners
body and then just kind of stayed that
way right so you have like Bruce Banner
walking around then you had the
Incredible Hulk walking around and then
they eventually you know merge back into
a singular being again but again it's
kind of cool here I mean literally The
Incredible Hulk just like rips open
what's basically this shell surrounding
Rick Jones and then you have Rick Jones
physical form back again so it seems to
have kind of been a way for for Al Ewing
to bring back Rick Jones right because
he'd been dead more or less it seems to
have been a way for him to bring him
back by saying hey look Rick Jones was
physically dead he was he was he was in
the ground that was the end of it and
then you have his body taken by the
shadow base initiative you know by the
Hulk initiative they cover min this is
basically like a shell that essentially
is is the new abomination and then once
that shell is ripped off and that
version of domination is destroyed all
you have left is Rick Jones's body as it
was kind of a cool theme because we
don't know if Rick Jones is actually
gonna come back or if he's just gonna be
left to be buried and that's gonna be
the end of it but it is kind of a cool
little moment a small little thing for
it for his character we don't really
know where things go from here and so
what is up happening is that in the
midst of all this you basically have
like like Bruce Banner who seems to have
kind of been whisked away we don't know
exactly when this takes place all we
know is he's essentially kind of yanked
away into this dark void surrounded by a
few stars she's hanging out with a mr.
immortal which is really weird and then
like like this this kind of you know
bright figure approaches him and says
like You Know Who I am do you know what
this is all the things you've ever done
over the course of your life do you
truly know what you are do you know what
you're meant to be and what you are to
become do you have any real idea what it
is that's going on here and it's kind of
crazy because Bruce Banner
is met by the arrival or really met by
like Metatron I'm gonna do you guys know
who Metatron is I feel like most people
don't because he's so obscure but
Metatron is basically the voice of the
one above all and it's cool because what
this means is the one above all it's
paying particular attention to
everything going on with Bruce Banner
wasn't that the one above all chooses to
act we don't know we assume he will like
we assume the one above all will act but
basically like everything that's been
going on here with the immortal Hulk
with regards to the one below all and
everything that's been happening on
earth has all gone noticed by the one
above all and presumably it will act it
will intervene or it will do something
and I don't know maybe it'll make him to
like Angel hope or something like that
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain and make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the robb for if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]